jawohl
[Musik]
zehn millionen menschen mittlerweile auf
der flucht innerhalb der ukraine und vor
allen dingen raus aus dem land vor allen
dingen richtung westen die
bundesregierung erwartet mittlerweile
alleine hier in deutschland eine million
flüchtlinge aus der ukraine schaffen wir
das das fragen wir jetzt die richtigen
fragen hierbei bild mit diesen gästen an
diesem sonntag nämlich mit stephan mayer
dem neuen csu generalsekretär
zugeschaltet aus münchen linda teuteberg
der fdp in der expertin mit manuel
ostermann den stellvertretenden
bundespolizei gewerkschaftschef und
zugeschaltet aus dormagen der mann der
dort ja richtig anpacken muss in der
neuen flüchtlingskrise den bürgermeister
nämlich von dormagen erik lierenfeld in
allen schönen guten tag im guten abend
wir alle erinnern uns in diesen stand
stunden in diesen tagen als besonders an
den berühmten satz der kanzlerin angela
merkel
wir haben so vieles geschafft wir
schaffen das ja herr meier schaffen wir
das auch das
natürlich lieber weise ist die
herausforderung immens und es steht ja
durchaus im raum dass die anzahl der
flüchtlinge die 25 10 216 zu uns kamen
jetzt noch mal übertroffen wird aber ich
bin der auffassung dass wir besser
gerüstet sind als 215 zu 16 dass die
insbesondere die kommunen die ja eine
hauptlast auch zu tragen haben wenn es
um die aufnahme der ukrainischen
flüchtlinge geht um die beherbergung
beherbergung um die verpflegung aber
insbesondere dann auch um die betreuung
der kinder in den kitas und in den
schulen dass die kommunen besser
vorbereitet sind als 2015 2016 man muss
natürlich auch sehen dass die
zusammensetzung der flüchtlinge dieses
mal eine andere ist als 2015 2016 bis
dazu kommen größtenteils frauen mütter
mit ihren kindern nach deutschland
weniger oder kaum alleinreisende männer
wenn dann eher ältere männer aber der
das gros der ukrainischen flüchtlinge
sind frauen die mit ihren kindern kommen
die auch häufig zu verwandten zu
bekannten reisen dort unter unterkunft
finden also die gesamtsituation jetzt
ist nicht eins zu eins vergleichbar mit
von 2015 2016 aber natürlich ist es und
ich möchte es gar nicht kleinreden eine
immense herausforderung für uns alle für
die gesamte gesellschaft wie gesagt
allen voran für die kommunen für das
kleinste glied in der kette aber
natürlich auch für die länder und für
den bund und beim bund bin ich der
meinung da müsste schon noch etwas
zugelegt hatten immerhin hat es anja
schmoll angelangt darauf gehen wir
gleich und detail ein herr ostermann
haben wir im moment mehr hinweise darauf
dass wir es schaffen oder mehr hinweise
darauf dass wir es nach gut drei
kriegswochen drei flüchtlings wochen es
nicht schaffen nicht gut schaffen also
aktuell geht die tendenz dahin dass wir
es nicht gut schaffen weil der
kontrollverlust nach wie vor anhält
übrigens nicht erst aktuell sondern
schon seit 2005 10 bis zum heutigen tag
und wir müssen natürlich reagieren und
zwar vernünftig reagieren in form von
grenzkontrollen und zwar ausschließlich
zum zweck humanitäre hilfe auch
strukturiert gewährleisten zu können und
das was herr meier sagt möchte ich
unterstützen 1 ist anders als 2015 dass
die kommunalen behörden vor ort anders
ausgestattet sind das liegt aber nicht
daran dass der bund hier besonders gut
ihre hausaufgaben gemacht haben an den
kommunen sondern dass die bürgermeister
und die landräte vor ort die
infrastruktur nicht komplett abgeschafft
haben sondern stillgelegt haben wohl
wissen dass da gegebenenfalls noch was
auf sie zukommen kann sofort nach oben
auch zur entfällt aber ich möchte das
noch einmal auch von der ampel wissen
ihrer vertreterin hier machen uns linda
teuteberg sie regieren jetzt anders als
25 10 216 wo man kritisieren konnte das
heißt sind sie jetzt in dieser mut macht
position würden sie sich diesen satz
jetzt zu eigen machen ja sagt die ampel
jetzt auch das schaffen wir ich bin
realistisch und ich sage gerne was nötig
ist damit wir es schaffen und das ist
dass wir das zusammenbringen nämlich
heißes herz und kühlem kopf also wer mit
einem warmen herzen menschen willkommen
heißt die die unseres schutzes bedürfen
der muss deshalb den kopf nicht
ausschalten und die registrierung ist
wichtig wir müssen wissen werden unser
land kommt einerseits ist er ja völlig
einerseits ist völlig klar bei den
meisten der menschen die zu uns kommen
liegen herkunft und flucht grund auf der
hand und deshalb ist es auch richtig
dass wir diese erleichterte aufnahme
haben erstmal ohne asylverfahren aber
die identitätsfeststellung ist trotzdem
wichtig nämlich damit wir einerseits
sieht das funktioniere mich dass ja das
liegt also da müssen wir noch mehr tun
also was wir liegen zum reagieren ja
also was berlin gemacht hat das letzte
wochenende einfach sagen wir setzen die
registrierung ausgeht nicht das wird
sich nämlich rechnen das ist ein
flaschenhals problem diejenigen die
sagen das können wir mal im mai
nachholen die verkennen die dimensionen
jetzt der der anzahl der menschen die zu
uns kommen wir müssen das gleich am
anfang machen damit wir auch zügig
wissen übrigens aber welche
bildungsangebote die regierung ja ja ja
in web surfer ein vorteil wenn auch wenn
die rohner da muss noch besser werden
aber es ist ja auch schon so dass der
bund gerade zu diesem was mich ärgert
ist dass diese geräte und die software
nicht hinreichend vorhanden sind aber
der bund stellt da schon den ländern
zusätzliche geräte zur verfügung mir ist
auf jeden fall wichtig dass wir es
erstmal als wichtige aufgabe annehmen
berlin sieht das ja nicht so offenbar
wie man das feststellen kann das ist
wichtig damit wir den wissen welche
bildungs betreuungs angebote brauchen
wir für die kinder und jugendlichen die
mutter bekommen und das jetzt noch sagen
welche müsste jedem klar geworden sein
wichtiger aufgelaufen war ist es nicht
bei allen klar das natürlich sagen weil
ich beides klar machen will wir können
das schaffen und das ist wichtig und es
sind menschen die unsere schutzes
bedürfen ja und wir müssen aber auch die
kleine minderheit auch von dies auch
gibt denn wenn wir unsere türen hier
weit aufmachen und menschen aus gutem
grund willkommen heißen gibt es auch
eine kleine minderheit von auch
kriminellen oder putins agenten die das
auch nutzen werden und die das auch gut
finden dass wir hier unkompliziert
menschen schutz bieten und im interesse
gerade der vielen flüchtlinge müssen wir
auch diese herausfischen das müssen wir
unseren sicherheitsbehörden ermöglichen
und deshalb ist die zügige verlässliche
registrierung so wichtig noch einmal
ganz kurz nachgefragt weil sie sagen das
hat noch nicht jeder kapiert also die
regierende bürgermeister von berlin
franziska giffey hat noch nicht kapiert
ihrer auffassung nach dass das richtig
wichtig ist dass das eine riesige
aufgabe ist also die sozialverwaltung in
berlin da sagen ja die polizisten und
diejenigen die in unseren
sicherheitsbehörden arbeiten die fühlen
sich da nicht unterstützt sondern die
beklagen eine ideologische amtsführung
dass die registrierung als nicht wichtig
angesehen wird dass die einfach mal
ausgesetzt wird
und da ist natürlich wichtig aber das
sagen wir auch auf bundes seite und auch
unsere sicherheitsbehörden und die
bundesinnenminister in das registrieren
ist eine ganz zentrale sache und hinzu
kommt übrigens dass wir den frauen die
hier ankommen unseren bahnhöfen dass wir
den schutz geben vor denen die jetzt die
situation ausnutzen weil wie gesagt in
letzer verantwortung steht das von der
bundesinnenminister nancy faeser die
ihrer regierung angehört möglicherweise
ist es da ja auch noch nicht ganz
angekommen dazu gleich mehr aber wir
gehen erst mal dahin wo die
flüchtlingskrise tatsächlich passiert in
die kommunen in die städte nach dormagen
wir schauen uns einmal an wie dort
aktuell flüchtlingskrise aussieht
märz 2022 in deutschland werden aus
turnhallen und schulen wieder
flüchtlingsunterkünfte aus
bürgermeistern wieder
flüchtlingsbeauftragte wie hier in
dormagen wer in den letzten tagen mit
hunderten von ehrenamtlern und auch mit
unseren kollegen und kollegen von der
stadt von der feuerwehr mit dem
hilfsorganisation malteser dlrg haben es
geschafft hier diese einrichtung
aufzuziehen das haben wir unterm strich
innerhalb von drei tagen geschaffen mehr
als 300 flüchtlinge aus der ukraine sind
hier angekommen vor allem kinder mit
behinderungen bürgermeister erik
lierenfeld hat ja gesagt ja zu diesen
kindern helfen anpacken ohne zu wissen
wie das alles zu schaffen ist also
realistischerweise glaube ich dass es
schwierig wird die menschen jetzt im
wohnraum unterzubringen wir werden jetzt
massiv daran arbeiten wohnungen
aufzubauen wir haben auch bereits über
200 menschen in privaten unterkünften
untergebracht aber das ist alles auch
nur auf zeit auch dort ist die situation
dass die menschen sich mit anderen
menschen die häuser wohnungen teilen und
ich glaube dass die unterbringung in
solchen unterkünften schon für deutlich
längere zeit notwendig sein wird als das
vielleicht aus der zeit 2015 kennen
also baut er die nächste tonhalle zur
flüchtlingsunterkunft um bereits die
dritte in seiner stadt
toilettencontainer stückpreis 35.000
euro wie viele noch davon niemand weiß
es
und jetzt ist er bei uns
herzlich willkommen an den bürgermeister
von dorma lierenfeld wenn sie uns da
gerade zeigen wie sie sofort bereit
waren zu helfen diesen kindern die
speziell zu ihnen gekommen sind viele
mit behinderungen mit geistigen mit
körperlichen behinderungen also das ist
eine besondere aufgabe besondere
herausforderungen für sie sie haben
sofort ja gesagt wer hat ihnen denn
geholfen damit sie helfen können haben
sie genug hilfe bekommen zum helfen
ja also sie haben eben die frage
gestellt schaffen wir das oder wir
schaffen das und da muss man zunächst
einmal fragen wie definiert sich dass
wir und in der tat sind wir da in den
kommunen doch weitestgehend auf uns
alleingestellt also ich kann auch meine
vorredner nicht ich sage jetzt mal
bestätigen bei dem hinweis dass wir
darauf gut vorbereitet sind weil man
muss wissen bevor diese situation jetzt
über uns gekommen ist haben wir bereits
viele menschen untergebracht alleine in
dormagen haben wir über 1350 menschen
bereits untergebracht das heißt die
einrichtungen die wir seit 2005 10
aufgebaut haben die sind voll also
mussten wir jetzt sehr schnell handeln
und da helfen uns tatsächlich die
ehrenamtlich engagierten
die hilfsorganisation ich kann da auf
eine sehr große breite schichten der
bevölkerung bauen und ohne diese
menschen
wir jetzt schon in den letzten tagen
probleme gehabt und eben ist die zahl
von 300 genannt worden wir haben zum
ende des tages wahrscheinlich schon fast
500 menschen die wir alleine dormagen
unterbringen mussten für die wir hier
einfach schauen müssen dass die versorgt
werden dass die genug leitung haben weil
die menschen die zu uns kommen haben
wirklich gar nichts und von daher ich
kann den hinweis von frau teuteberg was
die registrierung angeht zwar
nachvollziehen aber das ist tatsächlich
wenn sie erstmal gucken müssen dass die
leute brauchen dach überm kopf fahren
ist dass das was gerade vorgeht was
fehlt ihnen denn ganz konkret an hilfe
also wo bräuchten sie hilfe wo sie sich
im moment ausschließlich selbst helfen
können
ja also bei der frage wie wir die
menschen unterbringen wie wir gebäude
bauen wie wir an betten kommen das sind
alles dinge da würde ich mir natürlich
würde ich mich freuen wenn es da
irgendwie von einer zentralen stelle vom
land oder sonstwo unterstützung gebe
dass man irgendwo dinge eingelagert
hätte vielleicht weil es ist wie 2015
das habe ich alles wieder das ist ein
déjà vu für mich quasi dass wir
eigenständig unterwegs sind die dinge
organisieren und was ganz wichtig ist
das thema verteilung ich würde mir
wünschen dass man wirklich darauf schaut
dass die menschen in den hauptbahnhöfen
ankommen sind die großen hauptbahnhöfe
wo die menschen ankommen dass man von
dort wirklich eine registrierung
vielleicht organisiert durch die
mittelbehörden und auch landesbehörden
und dann erst die verteilung auf die
kommunen vor nimmt das gerät im moment
nur auf zuruf so habe ich das zumindest
hier erlebte am berliner hauptbahnhof
jetzt haben wir gerade in dem kurzen
film über dormagen schon gehört da
werden jetzt wieder turnhallen zu
flüchtlingsunterkünften bei ihnen auch
drei sportteilen so hatten sie uns das
gesagt wie ist das in der bevölkerung
aktuell das bedeutet ja möglicherweise
auch wieder das wird in vielen städten
der fall sein dann kein sportunterricht
oder halt woanders wird wieder
kompliziert für die bevölkerung das
wahrscheinlich auf lange sicht jetzt der
krieg wird nicht morgen nicht in der
nächsten woche enden und wie wird das
bei ihnen doch mal in dormagen
aufgenommen
zunächst mal muss man erklären warum
nehmen wir turnhallen war dort einfach
schon eine infrastruktur als mit duschen
und toiletten die sie sonst nicht haben
das ist die große schwierigkeit wie
diese container wenn sie noch welche
bekommen die kosten jetzt schon wieder
ein vielfaches auch da gibt es nichts
vorrätig und das ist das problem
die menschen nehmen das hier gut auf wir
haben eine riesen solidität auch hier in
der bevölkerung ich lade auch immer
viele menschen ein vorort sich die
einrichtung anzuschauen wenn sie die
kinder sehen und die mütter sehen was
für probleme die haben dann wissen sie
auch okay wir müssen im zweifel jetzt
mal den schulsport im klassenraum machen
oder wenn das wetter besser ist
rausgehen weil die turnhalle vielleicht
gerade von menschen belegt ist die jetzt
auf wenigen quadratmetern also wir haben
die familien wirklich er immer in räumen
untergebracht also auch in der turnhalle
haben wir richtige räume gebaut kabinen
die abschließbar sind damit eine gewisse
privatsphäre üblich sehr auch turnhallen
in anderen städten da liegt feldbett
nehmen feldbett haben sie vielleicht ein
bauzaun dazwischen das halte ich nicht
für adäquat für eine unterbringung von
familien mit kindern das ist für mich
eine sehr sehr schwierige forschung
aktuell wie viele könnten sie dennoch
aufnehmen kann man das sagen in dormagen
werden sie die wunsch infrastruktur
bekommen oder platzen sie im grunde
jetzt schon aus allen nähten und das
war's mir können sie nicht
wenn sie uns vor beginn des kriegs
gefragt hätten wie viele können sie
aufnehmen hätten wir gesagt 10 aktuell
habe ich eben schon gesagt haben ja fast
500 aufgenommen das heißt wir machen das
unmögliche möglich und das wird auch in
den nächsten wochen zu sein wir haben
eine fiktive zahl beziehungsweise eine
markante zweier unterbrechen wenn eine
million menschen nach deutschland kommen
kommen da von 812 nach dormagen das kann
man mit dem schlüssel berechnen wenn man
zuletzt davon ausgegangen ist das
vielleicht sogar bis zu vier millionen
menschen nach deutschland kommen könnten
sprechen wir hier von 3200 menschen die
nach dormagen kommen das sind zahlen die
wir schon bauchschmerzen machen weil bei
all den dingen die sie aktuell planen
haben wir kapazitäten für bis zu weitere
neben den 500 wir untergebracht habe für
bis zu weitere 500 personen aktuell das
treibt denen die helfen in der basis
schon tatsächlich den schweiß auf die
stirn schon jetzt nach drei kriegswochen
und vor der grenze stehen zehntausende
hunderttausende ostermann haben sie
hinweise wo die realen zahlen aktuell
liegen also laut bundesregierung haben
wir im moment etwas über 200.000
registrierte flüchtlinge aus der ukraine
haben sie hinweise wo wir tatsächlich im
moment stehen und wie viele das werden
könnten also konkret ist es aktuell so
dass 210.000 zumindest erkannte
flüchtete sich aktuell in der
bundesrepublik aufhalten die
dunkelziffer ist natürlich viel viel
höher weil wir überhaupt nicht
flächendeckend kontrollieren weil wir
überhaupt keine grenzkontrollen haben
und weil die personen die sich im inland
bewegen sich circa nach vier bis sechs
wochen erst registriert haben und dann
im nachgang die zahlen kommen also sie
hatten ja gesagt bis zu eine million ich
würde die prognose deutlich erweitern
natürlich immer abhängig von den
kriegsgeschehen in der ukraine
aber das zeigt wie massiv schnell in
kürzester zeit die zahlen angestiegen
sind und wir haben die große
dunkelziffer deswegen im übrigen haben
wir auch gesagt die notifizierung der
grenze für grenzkontrollen sind
zwangsläufig da kommen wir gleich drauf
hat heute berger sie experten gehen von
viel viel mehr flüchtlingen aus das ist
ja jetzt keine horrormeldungen sondern
einfach eine konkrete planung und worauf
muss man sich einstellen das heißt dass
halten sie für realistisch ist werden
viel mehr als eine million ja danach
sieht das leider aus mit diesem brutalen
kriegsgeschehen was putin da eröffnet
hat ist die größte fluchtbewegung nach
dem zweiten weltkrieg in europa die wir
da erleben und das hat eine große
dimension deshalb sage ich dass bei
allem ich kenne die praxis mit der
erstaufnahme wie schwierig das ist und
trotzdem weil wir werden das nicht so
einfach nachholen können deshalb betone
ich dass wir wichtig die registrierung
am anfang ist gerade damit wir die
kinder und jugendlichen die jetzt schon
zu uns kommen auch bald in
bildungsangebote bringen können und auch
die erwachsenen die jetzt gerade kommen
möglichst bald in arbeit bringen können
die dürfen ja auch schnell bei uns
arbeiten aber auch dafür müssen wir
wissen wer ist gekommen wir etwas
anbieten einem mast nach einem traum im
moment zu bringen
aber was was doch auch dazu gehört
übrigens zu unserer migrationsdebatte in
unserem land was ich schon wahrnehmen
sind doch riesige widersprüche das
bezieht sich überhaupt nicht verlieren
feld und dieses tolle engagement aber
ich meine ich erlebt eine debatte die
letzten zwei jahre wo ständig behauptet
wurde von manchen kommunen die sich
selber als sichere häfen deklarieren und
behaupten wir haben platz und jetzt wo
sozusagen offensichtliche
kriegsflüchtlinge sind und wir akut
platz für menschen brauchen da ist er
sehr knapp also es gibt natürlich auch
einige akteure in unserer
migrationspolitischen debatte in
deutschland die da sehr unehrlich unter
winkel in bayern nicht unreal gemeinten
streit ganz sicher möglich schneller
takt angibt sondern ein mann dabei diese
getan hat sich im feld aber andere
lassen sie ganz viel wohnraum und ich
finde dass wir so ehrlich sein um den
menschen gute bedingungen zu lassen sie
uns bei der frage bleiben worauf wir uns
einstellen müssen einstellen müssen in
diesen tagen und da lohnt im moment der
blick nach lemberg also in den westen
der ukraine wo ganz viele
binnenflüchtlinge sich aktuell auf
halten weil lemberg eben zumindest bis
vor ein paar tagen noch als sicherer
hafen galt dort in der ukraine und
darüber sprechen wir jetzt mit dem vize
bürgermeister von lemberg mit andré
moskalenko der uns zugeschaltet ist
schönen guten tag nach lemberg
moskalenko
wir sprechen die fdlr die flüchtlinge
die wir natürlich aufnehmen wollen dazu
verpflichtet sind und das auch wirklich
tun wollen und wir sprechen darüber was
alles noch auf uns zukommen wird in
diesem schrecklichen krieg vielleicht
können sie uns das schon ein gradmesser
geben denn sie haben ja ebenfalls
flüchtlingskrise sozusagen bei sich
neben dem natürlich alles
überstrahlenden krieg wie viele menschen
müssen sie aktuell in lemberg
unterbringen
wenn wir davon ausgehen dass nicht viele
menschen in der welt nicht diese
schrecklichen sachen vorstellen können
die in meinem heimatland
unglaubliche situation eine völkern
apathischen in mario kopper viele
gebäude zerstört hatten sie nur leider
war es genau heute morgen und so dass
wir wieder traurige geschichten gehört
haben dass eine kunst schule bombardiert
wurde von rosen in der vergangenheit war
es auch in der bildungs kliniken theater
was bombardiert wurden ist oft leiden
kinder und frauen darunter kader in
solch einer situation
frauen immer wieder auf der suche
gewesen nach sichere zuflucht sie wollen
ihre leben das leben mehrerer kinder
sichern
der russen ist es egal das militär ist
oder kinder sie bombardieren alle über
110 kinder sind ja schon von den dosen
umgebracht worden in diesem krieg in
diesem fall jetzt hier in lemberg haben
wir über 200.000 menschen
die
aus anderen ukrainischen städten suchen
uns gekommen sind
[Musik]
vertriebene sind bleiben auch jetzt
erstmal hier einige tage sie müssen
entscheiden wie es weiter gehen zu
wollen sie bei uns bleiben wollen sie
ins ausland weiter zu ihm möglicherweise
eine andere ukrainische stadt umziehen
insofern ist das für uns sehr wichtig im
moment ihr diese entscheidung nicht zu
treffen im moment muss ich sagen wir
sind noch in einer verhältnismäßig
ruhigen lage auf der luftraum ist sicher
insofern ist es für uns wichtig dass wir
eine berlinerin in ukraine schutz geben
werden die russen
der landesmitte und dem osten die städte
zerstören wir haben nur eine lösung wir
müssen bis zum ende durchhalten und
kämpfen es ist unser land sind unsere
steht wir haben kein anderes land hallo
kann ich nur sagen wir sind geeint wir
sind ein land und noch eine sache die
ich kenne welche richtung die gesamte
welt musste wissen dass
es kein krieg zwischen russland und der
ukraine ist es ist ein krieg zwischen
russland und der gesamten welt
was heute geschieht mit dem ukrainischen
kindern
betrifft auch alle demokratien in dieser
wertung des seine frage die sich die
gesamte welt stellen muss wie können
sich die ukraine die reale demokratie
unterstützen sie haben kartal die
menschen angesprochen die innerhalb der
ukraine geflüchtet sind und sich zu
ihnen erstmal geflüchtet haben und sie
haben dann gesagt die werden sich in den
nächsten tagen entscheiden ob sie weiter
ziehen oder in lemberg bleiben was
glauben sie wie deren entscheidungen
ausfallen wird nachdem wir ja zunehmend
auch erschreckende meldungen aus der
nähe von lemberg oder auch direkt aus
lemberg hören und sehen
in den letzten wochen etwa
hatten wir leider traurige nachrichten
bekommen dass ungefähr 40 kilometer vor
der stadt von
ein großes zukunft für friedenseinsätze
von russischen raketen getroffen worden
ist insgesamt acht flugkörper sind dort
eingeschlagen und das sind wirklich
schlechte das sind traurige nachrichten
35 unsere ukrainischen helden sind
gestorben über 100 menschen wurden bei
diesem angriff verletzt und auch vor
zwei tagen am morgen wurde wieder
blicken in der nähe des flughafens
angegriffen und ja wenn man so will ist
das auch ein signal das signal geht
nicht nur an lemberg oder an die ukraine
sondern auch ein klares signal an europa
niemand ist mehr sicher
nur 20 km sind wir entfernt von der
grenze eines eu-staates eines nato staat
also eine ganz klare botschaft dass für
uns im moment hier keine sicherheit mehr
geben kann
ich hatte bereits gesagt es ist
verhältnismäßig nicht im moment noch
aber es ist absolut notwendig dass die
gesamte welt die eu nato druck ausüben
was auf muss man ansonsten kommt dieser
konflikt immer näher an die eu was
würden sie all den menschen die zu ihm
nach lemberg gekommen sind raten würden
sie den nackten erraten ganz menschlich
ihr könnt guten gewissens hier bleiben
oder würden sie ehrlicherweise sagen am
besten wenn ihr die chance habt geht
richtung westen
viele leute die zu uns gekommen sind
sind natürlich unter stress
wir haben 500 standorte in der stadt wo
sie unterkunft bekommen wo sie schlafen
können wo sie lebensmittel bekommen wir
jemanden so um sie und bereiten sie vor
sozusagen nach ihrem nächsten
entscheidungen dabei kann ich sagen dass
viele leute bleiben wollen sie wollen in
ihrem land bleiben andere die natürlich
unter belastungsstörung stresst die
wollen natürlich die stadt davon lassen
und das machen sie auch und dank der
unterstützung von nachbarstaaten der
europäischen union im regelfall
sowas ist es wichtig dass die
unterstützung atmen
schwierigen
russland
angreift ich sagte dass wir kämpfen wir
stellen uns dagegen insofern können wir
eines mit sicherheit sagen
das was jetzt passiert ist unsicher wir
wissen nicht was heute abend passieren
kann noch vor vier wochen hätte niemand
sagen können dass die hauptstadt eines
der größten länder in europa angegriffen
wird noch vor vier wochen hätte niemand
gedacht dass die russen angreifen und
zwar vollkommen wahllos kindergärten
schulen sie wollen unser land dominiert
einmarschiert also wie gesagt unsere
reaktion kann nur einer sein hier
kämpften bis zum schluss es ist unser
land wir haben kann
überall gibt es auch leute die
zurückkommen
zurückkommen wollen die ukraine
im ausland gearbeitet haben sie sind
bereit waffen in die hand zu nehmen um
ihr land zu verteidigen um die
binnenflüchtlinge kommentierung dessen
was wir was wir tun können wie es nun
weitergehen soll das ist eine andere
entscheidung bereits viele sind
geflüchtet nach polen in andere eu
staaten und das ist eine persönliche
entscheidung einige von denen sind zum
teil wieder nach lemberg zurückgekommen
danke dass wir sie in unserer sendung
heute haben durften an den vize
bürgermeister von lemberg andrej
moskalenko danke ihnen der hier ein
appell noch mal an uns alle an die runde
gerichtet hat herr meier und ja offenbar
auch den eindruck hat wir haben das noch
nicht ausreichend kapiert dass wir
berührt sind von diesem krieg dass da
unsere interessen auch gerade durch die
ukraine verteidigt werden im kampf gegen
die russen kapieren wir es in dem moment
wo die zahl der flüchtlinge massiv
zunehmen wird ist das der punkt in dem
deutschland dort angekommen ist das zu
verstehen dass das eben unser krieg auch
es dort in der ukraine herr meier
natürlich natürlicherweise ist diese
dynamik die in dem kriegsgeschehen
steckt auch prägend für die deutsche
gesellschaft wobei ich schon der
überzeugung bin dass vom ersten
kriegstag an die solidarität des
deutschen volkes der deutschen
gesellschaft gegenüber der ukraine
gegenüber dem ukrainischen volk
ausgesprochen groß war er in bonn jetzt
aussieht insbesondere was die aufnahmen
was die aufnahme von flüchtlingen
anbelangt ist die hilfsbereitschaft die
nächstenliebe auch sehr ausgeprägt also
ich bin auch der auffassung dass dies
sehr nachhaltig auch anhalten wird
gerade angesichts dieser schrecklichen
schilderungen beispielsweise natürlich
jetzt auch vom vize bürgermeister
moskalenko aber
die diese schrecklichen bilder die sich
tagtäglich in die
wohnstuben der der deutschen bürgerinnen
und bürger projizieren die haben
natürlich eine nachhaltige wirkung und
vor dem hintergrund glaube ich ist eines
klar dass unsere gefühle unsere gebete
natürlich klar bei der ukrainischen
bevölkerung sind aber dass wir uns
natürlich auch soweit ist unsere
möglichkeiten zulassen dass wir uns auch
solidarisch zeigen beispielsweise was
die aufnahme von flüchtlingen anbelangt
mit wie vielen flüchtlingen rechnen sie
denn in deutschland
ich glaube das ist jetzt sehr spekulativ
das hängt wie schon erwähnt wurde auch
sehr vom weiteren kriegsgeschehen von
kriegs verlauf ab ich habe zu beginn
gesagt dass ich durchaus davon ausgehen
dass die zahlen von 2 15 216 übertroffen
werden wir haben jetzt wieder ostermann
schon gesagt hat 210.000 registrierte
ukrainische flüchtlinge 60.000 davon in
bayern man muss man auch mal dazu sagen
weil vorher vom bürgermeister lierenfeld
auch angesprochen würde es geht auch um
die gerechte verteilung die mahnen wir
gerade auch seitens der csu auch an wie
gesagt
heute berg hat ja gesagt unsere herzen
sind heiß und wir sind natürlich auch
aufnahmebereit aber das ganze gehört
natürlich oder zur wahrheit gehört
natürlich auch dass es einer gerechten
und fairen verteilung auch innerhalb
deutschlands bedarf und hat die
bundesinnenminister im jahr zunächst
auch eine finde ich etwas merkwürdige
position vertreten in dem sie gesagt hat
naja jeder ukrainische flüchtling darf
sich seinen bestimmungsort und auch sein
bestimmungsland selbst aussuchen vor
etwa einer woche hat sie dann eine 180
grad drehung vollzogen richtigerweise
wohlgemerkt und hat angemahnt dass die
verteilung nach dem königsteiner
schlüssel erfolgen sollte was bedeuten
würde dass ungefähr 15 prozent der
flüchtlinge auf bayern entfallen aber
derzeit sind eben knapp 30 prozent der
ukrainischen flüchtlinge in bayern
angekommen und das sind so wie hier
ostermann ja richtig gesagt hat nur die
offiziellen zahlen es sind ja weitaus
mehr wahrscheinlich noch bei
familienangehörigen bei verwandten bei
bekannten untergekommen unterliegen
keiner registrierungspflicht und da bin
ich bei einem zweiten punkt ich gebe
darauf heute bergrecht wenn sie die
berliner sozialverwaltung insbesondere
diese zahl die die sozialsenatorin kann
kipping kritisiert die ja abgelehnt hat
jetzt zukünftig der ukrainische
flüchtlinge zu registrieren und
interessanterweise auch angebote des
bamf des bundesamtes für migration und
flüchtlinge oder auch der berliner
landespolizei abgelehnt hat ihr bei der
registrierung der flüchtlinge behilflich
zu sein das ist aus meiner sicht schon
wirklich mehr als bemerkenswert aber
die registrierung ist natürlich zunächst
meine aufgabe des bundes das gehört auch
zur wahrheit mit dazu und ich habe zu
beginn gesagt da hat jeder noch luft
nach oben vor allem auch die
bundesregierung der verpflichtung die
ukrainischen ernüchterung mögliche
lücken morgen registrieren konnten
bislang nicht nach warum warum was ist
ihre erklärung hat heute berg warum hat
die bundesinnenministerium das nicht
durchgesetzt warum wurde nicht
registriert alle praktiker wünschen sich
dass und nicht um die grenzen dicht zu
machen um zu sagen jetzt ist mal gut um
wieder eine obergrenze einzuführen
sondern um einfach zu wissen wie viele
menschen sind im land warum wurde das
nicht gemacht also errät jetzt wird
registriert das wurde früher auch zu
wenig gemacht mir ist ich brauche kein
schwarzer peter spiel weil die tatsache
dass übrigens auch das darf nicht die
software einsetzt die polen einsetzt
obwohl die aus deutschland kommt ist ja
nun auch ein längeres problem was schon
länger blieben aber fehlt ja klar die
registrierung ist wichtig wir brauchen
übrigens auch nicht solche die man hat
wenn man herkunft was haben sie ja schon
gesagt habe sind leider noch immer zu
manchmal zu wenig klar ist was ich
eingangs gesagt habe was meine haltung
dazu ist wir brauchen beides wer herz
zeigt muss und darf den verstand nicht
ausschalten aber das haben wir doch
wirklich verstanden soll 25 10 216 also
war es aber einer praxis noch nicht
überall so umgesetzt und muss man ja
nicht betonen dass das man die identität
nicht feststellen müsse sondern beides
gehört zusammen menschen aufnehmen die
unseres schutzes bedürfen und aber wert
darauf legen ihre identität
festzustellen aber und mir ist auch
wichtig weil das eben finde ich auch
noch mal richtig und bewegend war was
hier der stellvertretende bürgermeister
aus lemberg gesagt hat das bedeutet für
mich doppelt also einerseits in unserer
innenpolitik dass wir eben die die
herzliche aufnahme mit der damit
verbinden nicht naiv zu sein was die
sicherheitsbedürfnisse angeht einerseits
und dass wir die aufnahme von
flüchtlingen nicht ausspielen die außen-
und
sicherheitspolitischen debatte mein
kurzer zwischen ford heute bewährt seit
gehört auch bei ihnen herr meier und bei
ihnen frau sie sind ja gar nicht für die
großherzigkeit zuständig finde ich das
so sagen darf herr lierenfeld mit
abstrichen der pakt nämlich selber an
und ganz viele im moment zehntausende
deutsche die zeit tatsächlich die
flüchtlinge zu hause aufnehmen das sind
diejenigen die großherzig sind sie sind
und vor allen dingen sie in der ampel im
moment zu stelle ich das ganze zu
verwalten das ganze zu organisieren die
registrierung zu organisieren deswegen
butter bei die fische sie stellen nicht
die bundesinnenministerium sie können
ganz klar sagen ist frau feser wenn sie
sich dagegen entschieden hat zu
registrieren ist sie überfordert damit
sie hat doch nicht nicht gesagt auch
nicht registriert wird ja soll aber
nicht gemacht es muss besser werden ganz
klar und wir haben da immer klar gesagt
das gehört für uns dazu wir müssen
wissen werden unser land kommt der bund
gibt den ländern jetzt auch er
zusätzliche von diesen pick geräten von
denen offenbar zu wenig lang chance
haben ein zelt geben noch um besser zu
werden wie viel zeit hat wir müssen das
jetzt alle so schnell und so gut wie
möglich machen aber ich finde diese
einstellung dass es überhaupt ein
legitimes bedürfnis ist wie ich saß auch
im november bei ihnen als für über
belarus und höher die situation da und
hab übrigens auch da ganz klar gesagt
das wollten viele damals nicht so gerne
in deutschland hören dass neben der
frage wie bewältigen wir die akute
humanitäre situation an dieser grenze
das kalkül von putin und lukaschenko wir
uns klar machen müssen dass wir dies
stabilisiert werden sollen dass sich das
gegen europa gerichtet und dass wir uns
da klar sein müssen dass wir mit den
polen und den balten zusammenarbeiten
müssen und die mich etwa im regen stehen
entscheidende unterschied zu der sendung
damals ist dass sie mittlerweile
mitregieren dürfen und genau das
gestalten können frau teuteberg den mai
noch einmal zu der frage ist die
innenministerin in dieser frage auch
nach dem was wir von herrn ostermann
gehört haben von herrn lierenfeld aus
dormagen gehört haben überfordert
ich bin ja weise der aufforderung der
auffassung dass die bundes in die
ministerin deutlich zulegen kann sie ist
ja durchaus sympathisch ich ich wäre ja
gar nicht vor dass sie das sie bemüht
ist aber wie gesagt was das thema
lückenlose registrierung anbelangt
aufgabe des bundes kommt das
bundesinnenministerium derzeit aus
meiner sicht seiner gelegenheit nicht
nach und auch was das thema faire
verteilung anbelangt mit verlaub der
königsteiner schlüssel soll angewandt
werden aber wiederum auch nur nach
auffassung der bundesministerin für die
registrierten für die flüchtlinge die in
den in den gemeinschaftsunterkünften
sind wir sind als csu der auffassung
dass für alle flüchtlinge die aus der
ukraine zu uns gekommen sind die
verteilung nach dem sogenannten
königsteiner schlüssel zu erfolgen hat
was eben zb bedeutet dass 20 prozent der
flüchtlinge nach nordrhein westfalen
kommen und 15 prozent dann nach bayern
weil eben derzeit manche bundesländer
allen voran berlin aber auch brandenburg
aber eben auch bayernweit mehr aufnehmen
als sie nach den verteilschlüssel
aufnehmen müssten herr meier hätten sie
sie waren ja im innenministerium sie
waren staatssekretär unter horst
seehofer hätten sie jetzt genau so lange
gebraucht mit der registrierung sehe das
jetzt nach drei wochen ganz genau so aus
sie gucken mal dass sie vielleicht im
april ein bisschen besser werden dann in
dieser flüchtlingskrise
es wäre natürlich jetzt sehr einfach zu
sagen ja auf der anderen seite möchte
ich natürlich auch durchaus konstatieren
es ist eine extremsituation aber wie
gesagt diese erste aussage der
bundesministerin war einfach aus meiner
sicht falsch ich glaube wir hätten
damals wir hätten die andere aussage
getroffen was den die die freiheit sich
den bestimmungsort selbst zu suchen
anbelangt und auch das thema
registrierung und das hat die
registrierung hat dann
15 216 dann auf initiative der
bundesregierung und des
bundesinnenministeriums deutlich besser
geklappt also ich fahre ich frage mich
ja verzeihung meinte ich wollte noch mal
die praxis check machen mit all ihren
fällt weil man fast sich tatsächlich
noch an den kopf das sind dieselben
debatten die wir 25 10 216 217 2 18
geführt haben und es ist doch
ehrlicherweise unser aller erwartung an
den start an den boden dass der dann
halt hilft wenn die krise da ist in
guten zeiten wo die sonne scheint und so
weiter da läuft das alles does not
unsere bürokratie aber die muss doch
dann funktionieren wenn tatsächlich so
eine große herausforderung kommt der
lilienfeld und jetzt stehen wir da und
die worte die sind quer durch die
parteien
die innenministerin die muss ein
bisschen besser werden richtung april
ja ich glaube wir müssen ja zwei dinge
sehen also zum einen ist sicherlich die
registrierung ein thema das thema pick
station ist angesprochen worden das ist
aber jetzt zumindest eine besserung
gelobt und das fangen wir auch in den
kommunen an auch da ist viel arbeit was
in den kommunen hängen bleibt die
eintragung ins azr also ins außerdem
zentralregister werden hier vor ort
durchgeführt das kriegen wir auch hin ja
das dauert länger als es einem lieb ist
was mir aber persönlich noch viel
wichtiger wäre wär mal eine klare
aussage wie es um die finanzierung steht
also ich war schon ein wenig erschrocken
als jetzt aus dem papier der
ministerpräsidenten mit dem
bundeskanzler ministerpräsidentin
rauskam dass man hier nicht nach
arbeitsgruppe einsetzt die ich glaube
bis zum 7 genau bis zum siebten april
sagt man wir machen uns dazu gedanken
zur finanzierung also entschuldigung bis
zum 17 april habe ich hier schon die
fünfte einrichtung wahrscheinlich schon
800 menschen untergebracht also da
erwarte ich eigentlich von unserer
bundespolitik und auch vielleicht von
unserer landespolitik ein deutliches
signal liebe kommunen belasten euch dann
nicht im stich da hat sie bis dahin
einmaliger weise aus bis dahin strecken
sie vor bis dahin gehen sie in die
miesen um das zu finanzieren wie viel
ungefähr wie viel wird dann fällig
werden dass gerade schon gesehen so ein
toilettencontainer kostet ob ich 35.000
euro allein also was haben sie im moment
für ausgaben und job
also man muss einfach mal sehen der
erste toilettencontainer die mir
gestellt haben hat für sechs monate 7000
euro gekostet und dann plötzlich für
eine woche später 35.000 euro das heißt
die die zahlen laufender weg wir
strecken dass ford die zahlen die
zahlung die wir über flirt bekommen über
diese landes finanzierung der pauschale
die ist mit bei weitem nicht auskömmlich
weder was die unterbringung mit dem
gesamten drumherum angeht als auch dann
später wenn es um die eigentliche
integration geht die davon auch noch
intern mit bezahlten soll also das sind
dinge das haut auf jeden fall nicht hin
wir gehen da jetzt in vorleistung mit
dem abgelaufenen möglichkeit jetzt uns
das kann ich ihnen gar nicht sagen also
so eine einrichtung wie jetzt hier für
180 personen wir sind jetzt gerade am
gucken wir haben hier sicherlich schon
300 400.000 euro investiert plus
laufende kosten also ich kann ihnen
sagen allein das catering im monat
kostet für die anzahl an personen rund
100000 euro das sind die zahlen die im
moment auf hinzu kommen und das ist nur
der erste schritt also da wird noch sehr
viel mehr dazu kommen erst die idee dass
der finanzminister dabei in den kommunen
zum beispiel in dormagen aus reute berg
brauchen wir brauchen eine gute
zusammenarbeit von bund ländern kommen
ja auch aber es muss natürlich aus den
ländern übrigens auch kommen und mir
geht es nicht um schwarze peter sondern
spiele sondern darum wie wir zur lösung
kommen wir brauchen ein zusammensetzen
den gipfel jetzt auch von bund ländern
und kommunen wie wir das gut stemmen
dieses thema dazu gehört jetzt ganz
praktisch wenn die verteilung zu recht
angemahnt wird dann muss man das so
machen dass man zum beispiel mit zügen
der bahn ganz gezielt in bestimmte
regionen jetzt menschen bringt so dass
wir die auf die kontrolle darüber haben
welche region nimmt jetzt wie viele
menschen auf bis vor kurzem war es aber
so wenn jetzt der verkehrsminister zum
beispiel dafür züge bereitstellt einzug
sind circa 700 menschen die da die der
fast und es waren bis vor ein paar tagen
nur 550 plätze insgesamt von allen
bundesländern zusammen gemeldet wie
viele menschen sie aufnehmen können so
ein beispiel dafür wir brauchen zb auch
schnell verlässliche meldungen der
länder damit angemessen verteilt werden
kann und das neue über die kosten
natürlich genauso gemeinsam gesprochen
werden
hilft der liebe liebe liebe liebe
stellen als pdfs fdp dem dem
bundesfinanzminister und die die aussage
von alien feld ist doch vollkommen
richtig und auch wie die klage ist
vollkommen berechtigt wir brauchen
endlich vom bund eine aussage und nicht
zusage dass der bund für die kosten der
kommunen was die unterbringung was die
verpflegung
der der ukrainischen flüchtlinge
anbelangt auf kommt zum beispiel der
freistaat bayern ist es auch seinerseits
in die vorleistung gegangen mit einer
milliarde der freistaat bayern hat in
seinem haushalt ad hoc eine milliarde
euro zur verfügung gestellt und der bund
stellt sich hier mit verlaub etwas
eingebüßt beim freistaat bayern es ist
da habe ich mich auf diesen mann auch
ein bisschen aber ein bisschen weniger
mitleid als dann bei einer hormonen
indoor man nur ein ganz bisschen weniger
mitleid gehören hermann weiß wie man
weiß wenn man weiß dass aus bayern jedes
jahr drei milliarden euro erreichen
berlin fließen dann ich habe auch gesagt
ich habe auch nicht erwartet einen
mittelgang hören ist ja politik ist nach
wie vor allen dingen nicht hat das sei
die handwerker war lange auf den kosten
sitzen bleibt und das ist ja schon dinge
hat diese massiven ausgaben und es hängt
jetzt an dem bund länder streit aktuell
vielleicht hilft es einmal sich
festzulegen herr meier frau teuteberg
wann wann haben sie es gelöst den knoten
damit die kommunen ihre miete bezahlt
bekommen ihre großherzigkeit bezahlt
bekommen die länder die länder stehen
gewehr bei fuß was verhandlungen
anbelangt und ich würde mir erwarten
dass wir zumindest die gleiche regelung
vornehmen wie bei der flüchtlings und
migrationspolitik 2015 2016 da hat sich
der bund nämlich bereit erklärt im monat
pro flüchtling 670 euro den kommunen zur
verfügung zu stellen und der eine
ähnliche regelung also erste ländern und
dann weitergehen mit der bitte die die
kommunen so zu alimentieren und eine
ähnliche oder eine vergleichbare
regelung würde ich mir jetzt auch
vorstellen für die aufnahme von
ukrainischen jährige sei klare aussage
600 670 euro pro flüchtling pro monat
seines hundes ab er muss der
bundesfinanzminister
rückwirkend ab ersten januar also ich
sag mal beginn der aufnahmen
ukrainischen flüchtenden seines motto
altenberg waren haben jetzt gemeinsam
etwa geklärt geht am donnerstag jetzt
laufen ja die ministerpräsidenten
zusammen und haben sich gelöst offenbar
genau aber da waren auch alle
länderchefs dabei oder so da war bis vor
kurzem eher damit beschäftigt täglich
seine meinung zur corona wieder beendet
wurde ja aber ich würde jetzt gerade so
getan wird als würde dort in bayern
alles perfekt gemacht und da würde aber
wie finanzminister muss es immer noch
mit wir haben jetzt haushaltswoche im
bundestag morgen beginnt die nächste
woche sitzungswoche mit wurde der
haushaltsberatungen beginnen und ich bin
mir ganz sicher dass man sich da jetzt
schnell auch festlegen wird und zu
lösungen kommt wir sprechen gleich
weiter schlafen ganz kurz durch auch mit
ihnen herr ostermann sind gleich zurück
nach einer ganz kurzen pause hierbei
bild die richtigen fragen
[Musik]
zehn millionen menschen die von putins
krieg fliehen eine million flüchtlinge
mit denen allein die bundesregierung
rechnet nach drei wochen von putins
angriffskrieg und wir die wir noch nie
mehr wissen wie viele eigentlich in
diesen ersten drei wochen zu uns
gekommen sind das diskutieren wir hier
bei bild die richtigen fragen und da an
der mit manuel ostermann dem
stellvertretenden chef der deutschen
polizeigewerkschaft der ostermann haben
sie in der eigene rechnung weil die
aktuellen zahlen das haben wir ja alle
hier in der runde schon festgestellt
nicht stimmen haben sie einzelne
hinweise wie viele menschen gekommen
sind zu uns aus der ukraine in diesen
drei wochen also was ich sicher sagen
kann sind 210.000 bis zum heutigen tag
aber die dunkelziffer da sind die
aktuelle zahl richtig und die
dunkelziffer ist natürlich wesentlich
höher ist nicht schlicht und ergreifend
daran weil zum einen wir überhaupt nicht
feststellen können flächendeckend
aufgrund fehlender grenzkontrollen war
wie viele personen sich überhaupt
richtung deutschland aufmachen und zum
anderen haben den zeitverzug bei der
registrierung der menschen bei den
kommunen von vier bis sechs wochen bis
die echten zahlen kommen aber wir dürfen
uns mal sicher sein dass auch die zahl
je nachkriegsentwicklung in der ukraine
von 1.000.000 nicht mehr haltbar sind
wir müssen uns der historischen
verantwortung bewusst werden dass wir
die größte flucht bewegung innerhalb
europas nach der nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg haben und dementsprechend auch
endlich entschlossen agieren und
deswegen sagen wir ganz deutlich die
notifizierung muss her damit wir
grenzkontrollen praktizieren können und
es dient und das sage ich in aller
deutlichkeit weil es mir wirklich
wichtig ist es dient nicht dazu
humanitären schutz gründe zu untersagen
und menschen abzuweisen es dient dazu
humanitäre hilfe erst vernünftig
strukturiert gewährleisten zu können
denn wenn man nicht weiß wer da ist
sowas in die maschen sind können wir
auch nicht wir wollen wissen mit welchen
zahlen rechnen sie aktuell also ist das
ein vielfaches an menschen die
mittlerweile ware und sind oder reden
wir über eine relativ kleine dunkelste
verbot von gehen sie auch sie sehen das
ja an der basis anhand der belastung
ihrer polizisten bundespolizisten
kollegen also ich kann und möchte das
natürlich nicht anhand einer zahl
festmachen aber ich gehe davon aus oder
wir gehen davon aus dass die
dunkelziffer vielfach höher ist als das
und wir werden relativ schnell klarheit
darüber erlange wenn die menschen sich
vor ort im registrieren aber noch einmal
das kann man seriös jetzt nicht
beantworten aber wir werden und auch die
bundesregierung wird sich noch wundern
über welche größen dimensionen wir
sprechen das wird gerade aktuell noch
tabuisiert und so ein bisschen weg
ignoriert und das ist bedauerlich jetzt
haben ja heute in dieser runde schon
festgestellt dass es mit der
registrierung hat nicht funktioniert hat
in den ersten drei wochen dass man da
besser werden muss dass die
innenministerin nicht gut genug war in
diesen ersten drei wochen nancy faeser
jetzt hören wir heute von den grünen von
heute bei ihrem koalitionspartner von
frau katrin göring eckardt dass man
einen nationalen krisenstab dort gerne
einrichten möchte innerhalb der
bundesregierung um frau feser zu
entlasten andere würden sagen zu
entmachten herr meier befürworten sie
dass vw sein das thema sekt zu nehmen
nachdem drei wochen und das jemandem zu
geben der sich damit auskennt
ich heute ist generell für sehr sinnvoll
einen krisenstab einzurichten ich war ja
selbst im bundesinnenministerium als wir
den gemeinsamen krisenstab mit dem
bundesgesundheitsministerium hatte im
zuge der korona pandemie also ein
krisenstab macht auf jeden fall sinn ich
möchte jetzt auch keine
vergangenheitsbewältigung betreiben aber
es wäre natürlich sinnvoller gewesen den
krisenstab schon deutlich früher zu
aktivieren aber ein krisenstab vor allem
auch der die koordinierung vornimmt mit
den ländern mit den kommunen macht auf
jeden fall sinn wer sitzt ihm dann vor
also auch wieder die
bundesinnenministerium oder der kanzler
direkt oder braucht es dazu eine neue
person
ich möchte mir jetzt nicht anmaßen zu
entscheiden wer diesen krisenstab leitet
wichtig ist dass er operativ gut
aufgestellt ist dass die leute auch
abgestellt werden krisenstab besteht ja
nicht nur aus einer person die ihn
leitet sondern entscheidend sind ja auch
die ganzen mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter die mit in dem krisenstab
arbeiteten die dann aus ihren
ursprünglichen arbeitsfeldern
herausgelöst werden das ist aus meiner
sicht auch ganz entscheidend dass man
den dass man erstens genügend personen
hat die mitarbeiten dass man auch
personen hat die qualifiziert sind die
also auch erfahrung haben beispielsweise
schon in den krisenstäben im rahmen der
korona pandemie bzw der letzten
migrations und flüchtlingskrise und dass
man diesen mitarbeitern nicht zusätzlich
zu ihrer originären arbeit diesen
krisenstab aufs auge drückt sondern dass
sie natürlich auch aus ihren
herkömmlichen arbeitsbereichen
herausgelöst werden und sich
vollumfänglich dem krisenstab widmen
können das sind aus meiner sicht ganz
entscheidende parameter für das
funktionieren eines derartigen
krisenstab ist wo der dann angesiedelt
ist ob im bundeskanzleramt oder im
bundesinnenministerium mit verlaub das
ist aus meiner sicht eher zweitrangig
frau teuteberg brauchen wir so einen
nationalen krisenstab hilft dieser
krisenstab all den menschen die jetzt zu
uns kommen als flüchtlinge hilft dieser
krisenstab ein möglicherweise neuer
krisenstab auch der arbeit von herrn
lierenfeld das der bessere infrastruktur
endlich bekommt dort in dormagen und
sich nicht um alles alles alles selbst
kümmern muss was wir brauchen und was
auch ein lernfeld an helfen würde ist
lösungen in der sache uns in den
wichtigen prioritären fragen auf das
notwendige zu einigen da kann ein
krisenstab sinnvoll seien einfach um ist
sehr konzentriert zu organisieren wir
haben ja zum beispiel vorgeschlagen das
hätten wir diesen wochenende dann schon
machen könnte tatsächlich auch so ein
gipfel bund länder kommunen um schnell
zu verständigung über die drängenden
fragen zu kommen das muss jetzt
geschehen und darauf kommt es an nicht
so sehr wie man das nennt oder wer wem
irgendwelche verantwortlichkeiten
zuschiebt sondern in der sache eine
einigung herbeizuführen damit die
unterbringung die registrierung dass
menschen schnell in arbeit oder in
bildungsangebote kommen dass das möglich
wird darauf kommt es jetzt an und dass
er jenseits irgendwelcher eitelkeiten
sondern wirklich in der sache bemüht
macht ihnen das hofft nokia lierenfeld
dass sie schnelle lösungen bekommen
schnelle hilfen bekommen
also wir haben bereits an dem dienstag
nach rosenmontag bei uns als erstem
einem krisenstab getagt und altweiber
war mir persönlich klar das ist ja hier
im rheinland als der krieg ausgebrochen
ist dass er was auf uns zukommt da habe
ich noch zu meiner frau gesagt da kommt
jetzt was auf uns zu also das heißt
jedem konnte bewusst sein wenn ein krieg
so nah an unserer grenze ausbricht dass
viele menschen zu uns kommen dh es muss
gehandelt werden es muss schnell
gehandelt werden die entscheidungen
müssen getroffen werden die finanzierung
muss klar sein und wenn man jetzt in
solchen strukturen arbeitet kann ich
wirklich nur empfehlen auch menschen aus
der praxis von vor ort denn in den
kommunen werden die dinge geleistet ich
bin noch mal etwas sagen zum thema
finanzieren was immer so außer acht
gelassen wird manchmal entsteht der
eindruck als würde man den kommunen
nicht so richtig trauen dass ihr das
geld richtig ausgeben deswegen muss man
da ein bisschen drauf schauen was hier
an tausenden von stunden an
ehrenamtlicher arbeit geleistet worden
ist um mich überhaupt die dinge ans
laufen zu bekommen dass das ist gar
nicht das wird gar nicht unseren
rechnung gestellt es wird auch gar nicht
dem bund in rechnung gestellt oder
sonstwem dafür müssen aber die
strukturen wirklich klar sein und da
brauchen wir zwingend und schnell
entscheidungen und lösungen und deswegen
kann ich nur noch mal appellieren
wirklich auf die leute vor ort zu hören
sich das vorortbahn zu schauen ich lade
jeden ein wirklich auch meiner dormagen
zu kommen ich glaube hier kann man das
ein oder andere sehen aber auch in
vielen anderen kommunen in deutschland
wird das gerade hervorragend geleistet
und da würde ich mich würde ich mir
wünschen wenn da wirklich der ein oder
andere sich das mal vor ort anschaut
damit man dann weiß aus dem was muss man
den krise stemmen bedenken denn nur um
da vielleicht abläufe innerhalb des
ministeriums oder zwischen dem
ministerium zu reduzieren das hilft uns
dann vor ort nicht wirklich weiter sehr
interessant was erleben fällt gerade
sagt er hat sich mit seiner frau war er
sich im klaren rund um karneval rund um
fasching vom rosenmontag dass da richtig
was auf uns zukommt wie er es
formulierte er ostermann warum dauert
das bei start viel länger als im
privaten oder hier in den kommunen und
warum haben wir auf den straßen dort an
den grenzen beispielsweise ganz schnell
ganz viele nämlich tausende zehntausende
freiwillige helfer gesehen aber zu wenig
staat die frage ist absolut berechtigt
die frage stelle ich mir auch des
öfteren weil es ihn zieht sich
grundsätzlich meinem verständnis warum
wir aus 2015 so rein gar nichts gelernt
haben auch bezüglich des krisenstabes
und dass sich private organisatoren und
bürgermeister vor ort besser
strukturieren als als der stadt als
solches ist auf der einen seite eine
erfreuliche erkenntnis in der aktuellen
situation auf der anderen seite aber
auch bitterböse bedauerlich und jetzt
wurde viel zu lange gewartet es sind ja
viele essentielle fragen auch die fragen
und übrigen wie geht man an der grenze
damit um schafft man rechtsgrundlage
überhaupt für die sicherheitsbehörden
für meine kolleginnen und kollegen dass
sie überhaupt tätig werden dürfen man
sagt immer ganz salopp die bundespolizei
in diesem muss machen aber unter welcher
rechts bedingungen müssen sie das machen
das ist überhaupt gar nicht klar und
wenn wir eins hätten aus 2005 zu lernen
müssen dann dass wir krisenfest sein
müssen und wir haben nun mal wahrlich
genug zeit und wir sind aus der
lethargie nicht aufgewacht und ich finde
es bedauerlich erdrückend und zum teil
auch beschämend dass wir heute 2022 in
dieser bürokratischen lage uns noch
befinden und den menschen vor ort den
bürgermeistern und den ganzen
ehrenamtlichen mit viel phrasen und und
wenig pragmatismus begegnen müssen was
ist ihre erklärung der frau teuteberg
das ist ja ein hauptziel ihrer
ampelkoalition lisa ihrer ampel
regierung gewesen man hat gesagt man
wird schneller werden man wird schneller
die bürokratie überwinden man will ganz
bürgernah auch reagieren regieren können
jetzt ist die erste krise nach knapp 100
tagen im amt voll da und sie lernen erst
mal dass es offenbar nicht möglich ist
schnell zu sein schnell zu reagieren
schnell zu reagieren also zum einen
beschleunigungen von vielem
planungsverfahren und so ist teil des
koalitionsvertrages in der planung aber
ehrlich gesagt ich kenne auch sehr gut
die praxis zum beispiel der
hilfsorganisation sie haben von bilder
aus tegel gezeigt ich kenne menschen die
dort tag und nacht arbeiten um die
aufnahme gerade auch von flüchtlingen zu
organisieren auch die brauchen eine zeit
um gerade zusätzliches personal
einzustellen und so also nicht immer
wenn etwas jetzt eine gewisse zeit
braucht ist das irgendwie eine frage von
und villen und mannschaft jetzt auch
nicht ganz schnell neue gesetze sondern
es geht jetzt darum sich über das
organisatorische schnell zu einigen wer
übernimmt welche kosten wie können wir
menschen unterbringen ja das was ihr in
polen besser aus schneller registriert
als die deutschen das tun das macht ja
aber da haben wir natürlich eine größere
debatte ich habe es vorhin angesprochen
ich glaube habe den eindruck dass in
polen insgesamt natürlich man ja in
vielem natürlich bei migration auch eine
andere debatte die wir gar nicht jetzt
bewerten aber sozusagen dass wir auch
mal sachlich darüber sprechen wie
trennen wir sachlich zwischen der
notwendigen aufnahme schutzbedürftiger
menschen einerseits und das ist bei der
ukraine flüchtlingen offensichtlich der
flucht grund dass sie hier zu recht zu
uns kommen und andererseits einer
angemessenen kontrolle auch einer
bekämpfung von illegaler einwanderung
dies aus anderen gründen auch gibt und
da habe ich den eindruck dass die frage
von kontrolle und auch diese software
zum beispiel die polen seit längerem
einsetzt da einfach schon länger da ist
ich erinnere noch mal an die disco
debatten über die grenze zu belarus
polen hat dann generell mehr fokus
darauf auch grenzschutz zu betreiben das
hat wieder eine ganz andere debatte in
deutschland schlusswort soll in dieser
stunde in dieser sendung erik lierenfeld
haben von der basis in dormagen herr
lierenfeld mir geht ein beispiel hier
aus unserem eigenen laden sozusagen
nicht aus dem kopf kollegen kolleginnen
von uns haben die kleine milana in
diesen tagen begleitet von der grenze
bis ja erstmal über österreich dann hin
nach berlin acht jahre alt und jetzt ist
milan mit ihren eltern in diesem fall
dürfte der papa mit kommen hier in
berlin angekommen und jetzt was ist
jetzt was halten sie für realistisch
wenn diese kinder alle zur schule gehen
werden die bildung in deutschland
bekommen werden bis es eine arbeit
gehabt für die eltern was ist
realistisch
also muss zunächst mal schauen ich habe
selber die situation dass ich solche
eine familie bei mir aufgenommen habe
mit kleinen kindern dh ich kenne selber
dass die kinder erstmal sehr
traumatisiert sind und ich glaube es
muss das ziel sein dass sie schnell in
unserem bildungssystem ankommen aber
zunächst mal müssen die die möglichkeit
haben anzukommen mit ihrer familie
anzukommen ein bisschen zur ruhe zu
kommen und dann muss man jetzt schauen
in den nächsten wochen dass die kinder
in die kitas und schulen kommen das
system ist darauf auch nicht auch
vorbereiteten weiten teilen das muss ich
so deutlich sagen weil auch da die
plätze eigentlich grad sind hier werden
wir kreative lösungen vor ort entwickeln
da bedarf es der rückendeckung der
übergeordneten behörden dass wir hier
eventuell mal out of the box denken
können und die möglichkeiten finden aber
ich hätte sicher dass diese kinder hier
eine gute heimat finden können das
merken wir jetzt schon dafür müssen wir
alle sie alle gemeinsam sorgen danke
ihnen für die diskussion herr meier nach
münchen frau teuteberg und herr
ostermann hier ins studio und verlieren
der bürgermeister von dormagen dorthin
danke für die diskussion das vorbild die
richtigen fragen an diesem sonntag zum
nächsten sonntag zurück
[Musik]